c'est la vitrine un peu darty de du
cinéma français qui doit donner envie
d'aller voir des films
alors malheureusement quand ça marche
pas dès le début après un des moments
les plus marquants de la cérémonie nous
a été offert par corinne nasiru la
comédienne culte de capitaine marleau
voulaient dénoncer la façon dont le
gouvernement traite le monde de la
culture est elle s'est adressée
directement au premier ministre jean
castex
sachez que la production ne fallait pas
qu'elle allait faire ça qu'au rythme à
dire où elle leur a dit je vais faire un
sketch sur peau d'âne et à prévention
ils ont vu ce qui est arrivé alors
corinne matinée et loisirs au coup de
génie ou qudra sera au coup d'envoi
regardez c'est parti c'est quoi passer
gordon
j'aime être le césar du meilleur costume
peau d'âne c'est bien alors j'ai un
autre costume si tu veux si je suis peut
être que les porcs c'est plus cinéphiles
à c'est carrie au bal du diable ça va
c'est trop trash aussi page et le
dernier a pris de ne plus un dernier
c'est qui veut la peau de roger la
thermite ans maintenant on est comme
savent tous nous y voilà
et sûr
alors vous voulez de coups de génie n'a
dit on pose la question aux
téléspectateurs déjà faut se remettre
quand même dans le contexte dans lequel
nous sommes nous artistes et du monde du
cinéma c'est qu'on est dans une
situation extrêmement difficile et je
pense que de toute façon je reviens
juste pardon sur marina foïs pardon
parce que je trouvais que vous aviez été
particulièrement bonne elle vraiment non
du fait qu'elles fassent ponctuellement
factuel en fait on est dans un moment
toute façon où c'était compliqué de
présenter les césars faut premièrement
socialement j'étais extrêmement content
qu'il ait passé c'est trop dur pour les
cinémas du monde entier
oui j'ai pas fini isabelle est pour moi
le césar de la route c'était l'année
dernière avec polanski mais je voulais
juste vous dire le moment politique que
vient d'eux de nous donner corps et de
mazères aucune actrice engagée la
d'ordinaire et c'était un moment très
très fort et de tout temps les artistes
se sont engagés politiquement
on a eu des collèges en alu emmanuelle
béart et c'était vraiment très très fort
que corinne masiero nous sommes ce
moment politique moi ça m'a vraiment
fait du bien est restée d'abord
changement qui a été soulevée avant il
fallait animer les césars maintenant il
va falloir les réanimer après cette page
sur la prestation après c'est pas la
même chose alors si vous désirez aller
sera pire des pires massy rond c'est sûr
que je lui reproche c'est pas d'avoir
montré ses fesses c'est qu'elle est elle
prétend représenter les plus faibles
d'entre nous les plus fragiles ce qu'on
appelle c'est pas une expression très
heureuse mais la france d'en bas et elle
pense que la france d'en bas elle doit
être présentée par la vulgarité
alors que la france d'en bas elle a
droit à la dignité se mettre nu est ce
que c'est vulgaire mais là de la manière
dont elle l'a fait avec les tampons
hygiéniques autour des oreilles je
trouve d'une vulgarité sans nom ensuite
je pense pas que la france d'en bas où
les gens qu'elle prétend représenter
fasse des fautes d'orthographe comme
elle
héritée du spectacle le plus grand de
vraiment quand on veut représenter les
plus faibles on essaie de rester digne
car ils ont le droit à la dignité ils
ont droit à un autre spectacle à mais le
seul hic à vous faire masser gilles
verdez découdra suis pas du tout
d'accord avec eric naulleau parce que
pour moi c'est un coup de génie pour
deux raisons c'est la seule qui ait
pensé aux gens dans cette cérémonie à
risque dans chaque cas où il était
nombriliste enfin elle elle pense aux
intermittents aux gens qui luttent et
elle le dit à lu nombril deuxième et
deuxièmement il faut mettre nue c'est un
courage absolue c'est même par mois et
par son courage elle dit je me fous de
tout je sais qu'en soins et pour les non
moi j'ai un adversaire eric franchement
j'admire son geste
géraldine non mais elle a des couilles
mais elle a des couilles pour quoi en
fait
lll combat quoi elle montre pas l'arrêt
des singes j elle remettait elle
remettait le césar du meilleur costume
j'ai gagné le césar voilà mais je vois
là mais bien son nom mais d'ailleurs dès
lors je vous dis c'est madame fontaine
pour la bonne épouse qui a fait un
travail extraordinaire un arrêt elle
elle en a rien à [ __ ] de la gueule non
mais si il y en avait ce numéro c'est un
numéro moi je trouve pourquoi pas sorte
de cabaret politique pourquoi pas mais à
ce moment là c'est pas les césar moi en
tant que téléspectatrice j'ai envie
qu'on parle de cinéma de larmes
d'émotion et de panache
j'ai envie d'aller voir ce film que je
n'ai pas pu voir avant avant le
confinement voilà mais j'ai pas envie si
tu veux je trouve - la neige qu elle l a
pris en otage le plateau pour en faire
une sorte de tribune politique était
complètement suivi dont géraldine mais
le monde du cinéma en ce moment ça des
gens qui ne travaillent pas à temps
qu'ils n'avaient pas peur et je sais que
nous ne sommes pas les seuls
alors c'est pas la fonction e tatou ai'a
nous ne sommes pas les seuls mais c'est
vraiment important et 200 par nous mais
aussi de questionner et question
politique c'est pour parler aux plus
grandes mais la saison dans une grande
précarité sa réalisation est très très
difficile je le sais pour plomber pour
les gens du show il ya malgré tout 200
films qui ont été produits en 2020 sa
tournée d'adieux attention grâce à
l'exception âge aux lois françaises
on finance quand même l'exception
culturelle française à coup de renfort
et de renforts et d'emilio 1,2 million
noront est injectée alors il ya des gens
qui lisent est pas rien s'il ya des gens
qui disent coûte génie la preuve elle
réussi son coup et on en parle et c'est
ce qu'elle voulait et voilà les camps
nazis mais quelle cause la fonte qui
s'est passé depuis cette séquence est ce
que les choses s combien fois on a cité
son nom et le nom de la lauréate
combien de fois un pour 1 million
stéphane tapis moi j'adore le cinéma et
du début des cérémonies jusqu'à la fin
je me suis emmerdé haut possible
c'était pas drôle c'était si tu dis que
les producteurs n'étaient pas au courant
de l'arrivée des des sketches qui elle
est ni enfin pardon si une faute
professionnelle dans mes baskets fait
pas sens après celui d'après je voulais
je vous dis la vérité
c'est très compliqué par la main je vous
le dis et ben alors la prenais pas oui
mais moi je vous le dit les objets mais
c'est compliqué lui dire ça c'est pas
drôle ça c'est drôle mais elle est
salariée
ah oui mais bon c'est compliqué mais là
le truc d'une brûlure thuan de caunes
ouais je trouve que tout on essaie de
faire son show le show de ses lacets pas
mais elle a fait du cinéma pour ça que
c'est la fête de du duel entre cérémonie
entre soi et pour moi c'est cette merde
quand j'aime le cinéma j'ai pas envie de
voir cette espèce de laideron
d'accord avec toi et ça c'est pas
dégueulasse
difficile à dire parce que tu passé mais
derrière ça hollywoodienne et c'est très
gênant pas manipulé ses comptes
en quoi c'est sexy mais des candidats si
vous jugez pas son physique madonna mais
je sais que je parle dans la folie
général à l'arrivée
magnifique m c'est dégueulasse mais
préfère l'histoire d'un ancien son
départ mais vous savez c'est ce qu'a l'a
dit on l'a vu elle a dit en fait que ce
qu'on lui reproche c'est justement date
d'avoir un certain âge et de ne pas
faire 1,36 alors c'est ça qui vous
dérange c'est à dire que si vous aviez
vous une femme plus mince mais qui nous
semblait plus belle excusez moi que vous
avez lu l'annoncé originale erwin arnada
excusez moi je moi ce qui me choque
c'est par exemple que enlevé enlever
votre action vous plaît ma chérie parce
qu'on remercie
ce qui me choque c'est que dominique
boutonnet président du cnc soit mis en
examen pour violences sexuelles et
soient encore en charge du cnc et ne
démissionne pas chaque mois c'est
vulgaire je suis fait qu'on peut pas
dire ça sur corinne ma douce